you or someone you care about
may have been diagnosed with leukemia
this video will help you understand more
about this type of cancer
and how it affects your body
your blood contains fluid and three
types of cells
red blood cells white blood cells and
platelets
these cells are made in the spongy
center of your bones
called bone marrow all blood cells come
from parent cells called
stem cells red blood cells carry oxygen
to your body's tissues
platelets help your blood to clot and
white blood cells help your body fight
infections
and any other harmful invaders or
diseases
leukemia is a cancer that originates
from certain white blood cells while
they are forming
in leukemia the stem cells in the bone
marrow make too many abnormal white
blood cells that don't work
properly this weakens your immune system
leukemia may also reduce the amount of
platelets and red blood cells
the main types of leukemia are named for
the cells they originate from and
how quickly they develop for example
lymphocytic leukemia
affects white blood cells called
lymphocytes in this disease
too many lymphoid stem cells develop
into abnormal lymphocytes
myeloid leukemia affects white blood
cells called myeloid cells
in this type of cancer too many myeloid
cells become abnormal and divide into
abnormal myeloblasts or granulocytes
which are different types of white blood
cells
each type of leukemia can be either
acute which means it progresses quickly
or chronic which means it develops over
time
symptoms for leukemia vary depending on
the type of leukemia
and which blood cells are affected
sometimes
leukemia has no symptoms but in general
the symptoms may include feeling tired
and weak
bruising and bleeding easily fever
weight loss and frequent infections
as part of the diagnosis your doctor
will try to find out the size of the
cancer tumors
and if the cancer has spread this is
called
staging staging varies with different
types of leukemia
in general an earlier stage or phase
means
less cancer growth and spread a higher
stage or phase
means more cancer growth and spread
throughout the body
the cause of leukemia isn't known but
there are some things that can increase
your risk
being exposed to high-dose radiation
having certain abnormal genes infection
with certain viruses such as the
epstein-barr virus
long-term exposure to certain chemicals
such as benzene
and chemotherapy drugs smoking
and older age as you deal with a
diagnosis of leukemia
continue to talk to your doctor and your
cancer care team